[Applauso]
buonasera a tutti
sono qui a raccontarvi alcuni alti e
bassi di quello che è la creazione di
un'impresa secondo il mio punto di vista
quindi start up da zero set up da un
foglio bianco sul foglio bianco la prima
cosa che c'è da fare è un piano un piano
che porta a una destinazione a un
obiettivo come fare un business plan
grazie alle esperienze degli attori qui
sul territorio ho imparato che un buon
business plan e fatto osservando e
ascoltando le il mercato attorno a noi
quindi osservare quello che è la
competizione già presente per la tua
soluzione ascoltare i bisogni e le
necessità del dei clienti e sulla base
di questo provare a sviluppare nuove
soluzioni soluzioni innovative per
prodotti o servizi
la terza cosa fondamentale nella
realizzazione di un business plan è
quello di capire chi fa che cosa
quindi
stat up è un qualcosa è una realtà che
non si fa da soli non esistono gli one
band business
dopo aver fatto un piano
fondamentalmente io amo i piani ben
riusciti
la realtà è diversa i piani non vengono
mai perfettamente perché la realtà è
mutevole la realtà cambia costantemente
e quindi ci sono come dire alcuni
assiomi che sono necessari per poter
portare avanti il piano è mantenere la
rotta verso l'obiettivo
il primo è crederci credo nel potere
realizzare passo dopo passo
milestone dopo milestone il punto dove
volete arrivare
il secondo assioma è quello di ascoltare
ascoltare i consigli dei consulenti
ascoltare i consigli degli incubatori
ascoltare i consigli delle associazioni
e delle persone che condividono valori
comuni
il terzo assieme quello di fidarsi
finanzi del punto di vista di tutti i
compagni di viaggio che sono con noi
la fiducia è un sentimento personale di
correttezza nella in qualcosa o qualcuno
è un qualcosa che non può essere
forzato ma deve provenire dalla
condivisione di valori di esperienze e
principalmente della comunicazione la
fiducia un qualcosa di mutuo quindi è un
qualcosa che va condiviso tra tutti gli
elementi di un team e qui
fondamentalmente avendo un team servono
solo tre cose la prima è mantenere un
ritmo mantenere un ritmo nelle cose
mantenere un ritmo nello sviluppo del
prodotto mantenere il ritmo e un
monitorare l'efficacia delle azioni
quindi monitorare le performance
bisogna essere un po maniacali su questo
perché perdere il ritmo significa
rallentare e avere ritardi che vogliono
dire arrivare tardi sul mercato vuol
dire arrivare italia ad avere una
soluzione arriva all'età di a ad a
fornire la soluzione ai vostri come dire
clienti
il secondo ingrediente è
fondamentalmente monitorare e capire
come vendere e commercializzare la
vostra soluzione perché sviluppare la
soluzione è il prodotto più bello del
mondo ma tenerlo chiuso in una cantina
fondamentalmente non vi porta da nessuna
parte
anche qui il concetto principale è
quello di mantenere il ritmo mantenere e
imparare dalle vendite quindi provarci
una volta capire dove sono le barriere
affrontarle con il secondo cliente e
così via è un processo continuo e come
vi dicevo la realtà e mutevole quindi
quello che riesce una volta poi uscire
una seconda ma bisogna imparare a avere
quella sensazione di adattamento a
quello che è
il mondo attorno a noi la terza cosa che
serve è fondamentalmente gestire molto
bene il team il team si fa con tre
semplici processi semplici dal punto di
vista come dire dell'acconto molto più
complicati dal punto di vista emotivo
nel senso che selezionare le persone che
vi sono affini per i valori con i quali
sentite di sapervi confrontare e
comunicare come pari a sviluppare
assieme alle persone accanto a voi il
loro percorso perché le persone hanno
voglia di crescere il loro percorso
magari e assieme a voi per un certo
periodo ma poi le strade in qualche modo
si dividono
detto questo le fai una startup vuol
dire fondamentalmente risolvere problemi
sempre nuovi e cercare di farlo sempre
nel modo più veloce possibile quindi
avere fantasia intuizione ma soprattutto
velocità nell'esecuzione e questo si
ripete tutti i giorni
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]